so it's so you know i i don't know my
girlfriend just jumped on my back about
it and it's like um
and there's a lot of things in my act
that are just way too edgy
you know because you know the last time
we did stand-up was before the pandemic
and now i'm back i'm tonight i'm doing
my fifth time back
first of all i can't do the time like
they say do 15 minutes
and i'm like doing nine ten yeah i can't
either it's so hard i'm so freaked out
our whole careers i don't think we've
spent a week off stage
exactly even if you go do a movie you
find a place where you can do it and now
it's been a year and a half or two years
and then they see stuff like
it's like riding a bike no it's like
right flying an
airplane that you've never flown an
airplane before that's how difficult it
is
i can't imagine well i was actually
reading some of
his joke what's going on they're getting
poppy
what are you worried about sorry i
didn't she got scared uh bobby
left his coffee on our desk he went to
grab his coffee
and he was like what's going on
no no i was saying that i was reading
he's been writing jokes at night i guess
his notes
and then he was looking at them the
other day in front of us and he goes
can you tell me what this means he
doesn't even know what his own jokes
mean
when he writes them down and i can't i
have no idea what they mean
yeah at all well i'm going to be totally
honest with you i ca i have trouble
sleeping me too so i i take some gummies
at night
marijuana gummies yeah okay no just
gummies
i like it's a special treat if i've been
a good boy if i've been a really good
boy then i get candies
i get candies to go to sleep no i took
uh gummy just to sleep i don't i'm not
partying and it's legal
yeah right is this conversation gonna
get me canceled no
no no it's illegal it's like saying you
took a shot of whiskey or whatever right
yeah is it it's all okay so i take a
couple of gummies and then i'm lying in
bed
and this must happen to you you have an
idea right
and you write it down or text it into
your thing except
i'm a cheap date and gummies really
affect me hard
and a lot of those things that i write
down don't make sense
right i mean do you write full sentences
or they're just little words like
panda bear you know i mean and then like
lollipop
do you do that yes i have a new joke
with panda bears and lollipops
sounds like a song what is your new joke
with the panda bears this is a premise i
have no punch liner
it's just an idea to use a candy bar i'm
not so
alone in this yeah you really wrote down
panda bears no i was kidding man
i don't love that no it's a lie again
have you ever done something well i
guess that's on stage
have i done some what something on stage
that now you regret
yeah what well you know there's a lot of
like
bits like i used to when i had a i don't
know i'm too
afraid to even say it on here
but i will okay right so i used to have
a mohawk
right right and i and i used to have an
opening line i look like an american
indian with down syndrome
right right right and they used to get a
really big laugh and i used to go
[Laughter]
and this is like 12 years ago right i
used to do this bit right
i would never do that joke now